we already know that the product rule
tells us that if we have the comp if we
have the product of two functions so
let's say f of x
and g of x and we want to take the
derivative of this
we want to take the derivative of this
business
this is just going to be equal to the
derivative of the first function f prime
of x
times the second function
times g of x
plus
plus
the first function so not even taking
its derivative so plus f of x times the
derivative of the second function
times the derivative of the second
function so two terms in each term we
take the derivative of one of the
functions and not the other and then we
switch so over here's the derivative of
the of f not of g here it's the
derivative of g not of f that's this is
hopefully a little bit of review this is
the product rule now we're essentially
going to do is reapply the product rule
to do what many of your calculus books
might call the quotient rule i have
mixed feelings about the quotient rule
if you know it it might make some
operations a little bit faster but it
really comes straight out of the product
rule and i frankly always forget the
quotient rule and i just rederive it
from the product rule so let's see what
we're talking about so let's imagine if
we had
a an expression that could be written as
f of x divided by
g of x and we want to take the
derivative of this business
the derivative of f of x over g of x
the key realization is to just recognize
that this is the same thing as the
derivative of
instead of writing f of x over g of x we
could write this as f of x
f of x times g of x to the negative 1
power
g of x to the negative
1 power and now we can use the product
rule with a little bit of the chain rule
what is this going to be equal to
well we just use the product rule it's
the derivative of the first function
right over here so it's going to be f
prime of x
f prime of x
times the just the reg the second
function which is just
g of x to the negative 1 power
g of x to the negative 1 power
plus
plus
the first function which is just f of x
plus f of x times the derivative of the
second function and here we're going to
have to use a little bit of the chain
rule the derivative of the outside which
we could kind of view as something to
the negative 1 power with respect to
that something is going to be negative 1
times that something which in this case
is g of x to the negative 2 power and
then we have to take the derivative of
the inside function with respect to x
which is just g
prime
of x and there you have it we have found
the derivative of this using the product
rule and the chain rule now this is not
the form that you might see when people
are talking about the quotient rule in
your math book so let's see if we can
simplify this a little bit
all of this is going to be equal to
we can write this term right over here
as f prime of x
as f prime of x over g of x
f prime of x over g of x and we can
write all of this as
we put this negative sign out front we
have negative
f of x
negative
f of x times g prime of x times g prime
of x
g prime of x and then all of that over g
of x squared
all of that over let me write this a
little bit neater all of that over
g of x squared
g
of x squared and it still isn't the form
that you typically see in your calculus
book to do that we just have to add
these two fractions so let's multiply
the numerator and the denominator here
by g of x so that we have everything in
the form of g of x squared in the
denominator
so if we multiply the numerator by g of
x we'll get g of x right over here and
then the denominator will be g of x
squared and now we're ready to add
and so we get
we get the derivative of f of x over g
of x is equal to
the derivative of f of x
times g of x
times g of x
minus not plus anymore minus let me
write it in white
minus
minus
f of x
minus
f of x
times g prime of x times g prime of x
all of that over
all of that over
g of x squared g of x squared so once
again you can always derive this from
the product rule and the chain rule
sometimes this might be convenient to
remember in order to work through some
problems of this form a little bit
faster and if you wanted to kind of see
the pattern between the product rule and
the quotient rule the derivative of one
function
just times the other function instead of
adding the derivative of the derivative
of the second function times the first
function we now subtract it and all of
that is over the second function squared
whatever was in the denominator it's all
of that squared so when we're taking the
derivative of the function in the
denominator up here there's a
subtraction and then we are also putting
everything over the second function
squared